staff at Wuhan Hospital are working
around the clock to identify a mystery
virus which has been linked to stars
severe acute respiratory syndrome at
least three people have died and the
number of those confirmed to have the
virus is growing but Rani's officials
say the outbreak is under control
identified new cases have been admitted
to a designated hospital and we have
concentrated resources experts to treat
the patients in one place the virus
which causes pneumonia like symptoms
originated in a Wuhan seafood and meat
market cases have been confirmed in
Beijing and Shenzhen and found in
Chinese visitors to Japan Thailand and
South Korea human to human transmission
has not been ruled out and that's a
problem because this week marks the
official beginning of China's busiest
travel season hundreds of millions are
using public transit ahead of Chinese
New Year celebrations checks are being
conducted in railway stations and
airports but that hasn't eased the
growing concern about the spread of the
virus people here are looking to the
government to do more to keep them safe
I don't think the government is do
enough because I'm just not hearing
enough details about it I don't think
they will give us a true number of those
infected I'm worried and that's why I
wear masks when I'm out others say they
trust the government's handling of the
virus I believe the government will give
us fast and accurate information I think
they're more worried than the public
they will have to figure out how to deal
with it so I'm not worried but the
outbreak is bringing back uneasy
memories of the 2003 SARS outbreak which
killed almost 800 people worldwide and
left more than 8,000 sick authorities
initially withheld information about the
epidemic leading some to question the
Chinese government's transparency around
the new virus British researchers say
there could be as many as 1700 cases the
World Health Organization has sent a
research team to Wuhan to analyze the
extent of human-to-human transmission we
need to collect more and more
information so this is obviously the new
diseases and so many things we still
don't know videos are circulating on
Chinese social media of passengers being
tested on flights from Wuhan but the
government has appealed to the public to
remain calm eight people were arrested
earlier this month for spreading rumors
about the outbreak online but preventing
the spread of the virus may not be as
straightforward as controlling the
spread of information between you al
Jazeera Beijing